il diffuse et ils diffusent plus vite
chaque semaine nous sommes vous le voyez
sur la courbe qui apparaît sur votre
écran nous sommes sur un plateau montant
un peu plus de vingt mille cas positifs
diagnostiquées chaque jour c'est
beaucoup c'est moins que les 50 mille
cas de la vague de l'automne que nous
avions par jour mais cela reste à un
niveau élevé et quand on regarde la
tendance cela augmente d'environ 10% par
semaine en moyenne depuis trois semaines
donc nous faisons le constat que le
virus circule beaucoup et qu'il circule
un peu plus chaque semaine
s'il y a un mois encore on constatait
une grande différence entre l'ouest et
l'est du pays l'est étant le plus touché
aujourd'hui la dynamique épidémique
s'est progressivement équilibré vous le
voyez sur la carte d'un côté là où nous
avons mis en place un couvre-feu à 18h30
au tout début du mois de janvier
il ya d'abord eu un effet réel de baisse
de la pression épidémique
puis une stabilisation dans le reste du
pays là où il n'y avait pas de couvre
feu au tout début du mois de janvier
l'épidémie a été un peu plus forte ces
dernières semaines ce qui veut dire que
globalement le couvre-feu à 18h à une
efficacité probablement at il permis que
nous évitions de connaître la même vague
épidémique que nombre de nos voisins
mais à l'évidence cette efficacité
s'estompe et à l'évidence cela ne suffit
pas à faire reculer le virus j'y
reviendrai vous le savez les décisions
que nous avons prises depuis un an ont
toujours été fondée sur un critère
sanitaires c'est à dire sauver des vies
éviter des cas graves et limiter le plus
possible la saturation des hôpitaux et
des services de réanimation pendant
plusieurs semaines à l'issue du second
confinement nous avons constaté que
semaine après semaine il y avait moins
de patients qui entrait à l'hôpital que
deux patients qui en sortaient guéri
nous sommes donc passés de 5000 cas en
réanimation à environ 2500 au début de
l'hiver
ensuite pendant plusieurs semaines il
ait eu un bilan entrées sorties à
pital neutre c'est-à-dire qu'il y avait
autant de patients qui étaient admis à
l'hôpital est en réanimation que de
sortie mais un bilan neutre à niveau
élevé puisque avec toujours au minimum
2500 patients en réanimation pour duke
au vide et un peu plus de 24 mille
patients en service d'hospitalisation
cours du coc vide ça reste beaucoup pour
nos hôpitaux et d'ailleurs plusieurs
d'entre eux n'ont pas été capables de
reprogrammer toutes les activités de
soins destinés à des patients qui
avaient besoin de soins orco vide et qui
avait été déprogrammé ces deux dernières
semaines
la situation a encore évolué il ya
désormais plus de cas graves qui
nécessitent des soins à l'hôpital que
deux patients qui guérissent et peuvent
s'en sortir
ça veut dire que la pression sanitaires
et la tension hospitalière augmente à
nouveau deux chiffres pour s'en rendre
compte
250 patients en moyenne sont admis
chaque jour dans les réanimations en
france c'était 170 patients en décembre
et jusqu'à début janvier plus de 3100
patients atteints du coc vide se trouve
désormais en réanimation et plus de
27000 en hospitalisation pour mémoire il
y avait au moment nous avons décidé du
second confinement près de 3400 patients
en réanimation contre 3100 actuellement
et 22 mille patients à l'hôpital contre
27 mille actuellement mais à nouveau au
moment où le second confinement a été
prononcé nous étions alors dans une
croissance exponentielle
une véritable vague épidémique une
croissance exponentielle du nombre de
cas graves du nombre de diagnostics et
du nombre de décès comparé à la
situation de cet automne deux paramètres
sont à prendre en compte de paramètres
majeurs
à paramètres positifs d'abord mais aussi
un paramètre qui nous inquiète le
paramètre positif c'est évidemment la
vaccination des personnes vulnérables
qui a commencé dans notre pays qui se
fait désormais à un rythme rapide qui va
produire des effets de protection mais
dont on sait qu'il prendra plusieurs
mois
compte tenu des doses disponibles le
paramètre qui nous inquiète ce sont
évidemment c'est variant du virus
ils ont été identifiés en angleterre
en afrique du sud au brésil ces variants
sont plus contagieux que le coc vite 19
classique qui sévit dans notre pays
depuis un an
ces variants circulent désormais dans le
monde entier ainsi qu'en france nous
avons déployé tous les moyens
diagnostiques dont nous disposons pour
traquer ces variants partout où ils sont
identifiés et pour briser les chaînes de
contamination desquels apparaissent
cela nous permet de gagner un temps
précieux un temps utile en particulier
pour vacciner les plus fragiles d'entre
nous parmi ces moyens de diagnostic
il y à la mobilisation de toutes les
plateformes de séquençage génétique du
pays
il y à l'utilisation nouvelles de kits
diagnostiquant pcr multiplex c'est à
dire des tests pcr spécifique qui
détecte les variantes des personnes qui
sont positives au coronavirus il ya
également ce qu'on appelle le traçage de
contact racing qui est encore plus serré
merci aux équipes des agences régionales
de santé pour leur action déterminée il
ya également la proposition systématique
qui est faite à tous les patients qui
sont isolés parce qu'ils sont positifs
oco vide et aux variants de recevoir la
visite chez eux d'un infirmier ou d'une
infirmière à domicile pour vérifier que
les conditions sanitaires mais également
sociales sont réunis qui leur permettent
de respecter les conditions d'isolement
mais aussi pour proposer de tester au
domicile
tout l'entourage de la personne positive
ou du cas contacts à ce stade se sont
déjà plusieurs milliers de visites à
domicile qui ont été lancés et le
dispositif continue de monter en
puissance se disait malgré tous nos
efforts les variants circule activement
en france au cours du mois de janvier on
estime être passé de quelques 500
patients environ par jour
atteint de ces variants début du mois de
janvier
c'est plus élevé que ce que nous
pensions à plus de 2000 patients par
jour
atteint de ces variants actuellement
essentiellement c'est le variante
découvert en angleterre le fameux voc
2020 mais également à minima le variant
d'origine sud-africaine le 501 y v2 les
enseignements que nous tirons des pays
dans lesquels ces variants ont circulé
plus tôt et plus fort que chez nous sont
qui sont susceptibles d'entraîner une
vague épidémique très
forte plus forte encore que les
précédentes compte tenu de la forte
contagiosité de ses variantes
c'est le cas notamment vous pouvez le
voir en angleterre et plus récemment en
espagne ou encore au portugal
le fait que ces variants se propage dans
notre pays nous laisse penser que le
couvre-feu et l'ensemble des mesures de
contrôle en vigueur dans notre pays sont
certes utile mais probablement pas
suffisantes
ce que nous voulons éviter c'est une
épidémie dans l'épidémie qui n'est pas
encore véritablement visible en france
mais dont tout nous laisse à penser
qu'elle sera une réalité très vite et
très fort
si nous ne faisons rien ces variantes
les considère un peu comme des nouveaux
virus
appelant de nouvelles mesures pour nous
protéger j'ajoute que les scientifiques
et les laboratoires reste confiant sur
l'efficacité des vaccins raison pour
laquelle il reste tout aussi important
de poursuivre notre campagne de
vaccination des messieurs nous avons
toujours agi pour préserver la santé des
français
nous avons toujours pris toutes les
actions nécessaires pour préserver
l'économie de notre pays en parallèle
nous savons les sacrifices demandés aux
français les bouleversements occasionnés
dans leur vie sociale culturelle
éducative sportive familiale
professionnelle
nous n'ignorons pas l'impact les
conséquences psychologiques réel et que
nous suivons au quotidien les français
font preuve depuis plus d'un an d'un où
près d'un an d'un remarquable esprit de
solidarité et de responsabilité
nous devons tenir encore l'état reste à
vos côtés dans cette épreuve collective
toutes les mesures nécessaires pour
soulager apaisé protégés ont été sont et
seront prises je pense par exemple à l'
annonce faite par le président de la
république d'un chèque psy destiné aux
étudiants je pense à l'envoi de 45
millions de masques gratuits par la
poste chez 7 millions de français aux
conditions de vie plus vulnérables je
pense au déploiement de nombreuses
lignes d'écouté à la mobilisation
renforcée des psychologues
nous devons aussi donner des
perspectives aux français quelles que
soient les mesures qui seront prises
dans les prochains jours ces
perspectives sont essentiels elles
porteront de l'espoir après des temps
difficiles et je suis convaincu que nous
serons les dessiner
ensemble voilà je vous ai présenté
brièvement la situation sanitaire dans
notre pays avec je le redis ces
certitudes mais aussi ses interrogations
ses espoirs mais aussi ses risques
c'est sur ces bases une concertation est
lancée j'y participerai dans quelques
minutes
aux côtés du premier ministre avec
l'ensemble des représentants de la
classe politique de notre pays mais
également les représentants des
syndicats du patronat des collectifs
d'élus d'associations
je vous remercie bonjour monsieur le
ministre florian tardif pour ses news
groupe canal+ vous avez réalisé
récemment une étude sur 137 centres de
vaccination pour l'étude notamment de la
6ème dose de father une sixième dawes a
pu être extraite dans 86% des flacons
c'est à dire que 14 doses achetées
commandes et donc par la france sont
perdues toutes les à 600 doses est ce
que vous avez demandé au groupe pfizer
du mtq de revenir sur sa décision de
considérer que chaque flacon contient
s'il ose on sait que par exemple nos
voisins souhait dont deux suédois ont
décidé potentiellement d'arrêter des
paiements en attente de clarification du
groupe
de façon générale il faut savoir que la
commission européenne a passé des
contrats avec un certain nombre de
laboratoires
l'europe a eu raison de le faire si nous
avions été tributaire d'un seul vaccin
d'un seul laboratoire comme certains
pays lointains l'ont fait peut être
n'aurions pas pu nous n'aurions nous pas
pu commencer à vacciner nos populations
la diversité des vaccins est une chance
et à l'heure à laquelle je vous parle
l'agencé européenne du médicament est
réunie qui doit je l'espère dans la
journée ou donner un verdict sur un
nouveau vaccin
celui développé par astrazeneca nous
verrons quelles seront les conditions
d'utilisation l'europe se disent à
passer des contrats fermes avec un
ensemble de laboratoires avec des
prévisions de livraisons de doses
je souhaite évidemment que les
laboratoires respecte leur partie du
contrat et puissent livrer dans les
meilleurs conditions et les meilleurs
délais l'ensemble des doses qui avait
été engagé s'agissant du vaccin
kaiser la question portait sur
l'utilisation la possibilité d'extraire
une sixième d'eau dans un flacon qui
était censé en contenir
les autorités européennes ont donné leur
feu vert considérant qu'on était dans la
plupart des cas en capacité d'extraire
si dose c'est le cas en france je vous
confirme que en moyenne sont extraites
5,9 doses par flacon
donc c'est pas complètement 6 mais ce
n'est pas cinq non plus est par ailleurs
pfizer a fait face à des difficultés
d'approvisionnement de livraison qui
vous savez ont été plus faibles la
semaine dernière qu'elle aurait dû
l'être en portant des conséquences sur
l'organisation d'un certain nombre de
vaccinations qui avait été prévu encore
une fois nous faisons tout pour que
chacun puisse respecter sa part
d'engagement c'est essentiel on sait que
plusieurs scénarios sont sur la table
aujourd'hui est ce que vous vous plaidez
pour un confinement souple comme à
l'automne ou limiter aux week-ends ou
bien pour un confinement très serré
comme l'a évoqué gabriela talent
et puis deuxième question c'est que la
circulation des variants ça va peser
très lourd dans ces nouvelles
restrictions
quand est ce que nous aurons les
résultats de la nouvelle opération de
séquençage et avez vous fixé un niveau
de circulation du variant britannique
qui déclencherait un niveau de
confinement plus strictes pour votre
première question d'abord j'ai émis des
recommandations des propositions nous
nous avons échangé longuement guerre
comme nous le faisons chaque semaine
autour du président de la république et
du premier ministre en conseil de
défense et sécurité nationale ce que
j'ai dit dans l'enceinte du conseil de
défense et sécurité nationale a vocation
à rester dans l'enceinte du conseil de
défense et sécurité nationale je crois
que nous avons à tous nous appliquer
cette hygiène de fonctionnement c'est
aussi un cadre qui garantit la sécurité
et la possibilité d'avoir des échanges
qui sont libres vous comprendrez que je
ne répondrai pas à votre première
question sur la deuxième question que
vous m'avez posé qui portait sur est ce
qu'il ya un seuil de circulation des
variantes
ce que nous regardons c'est que nous
avons des courbes à nouveau pardon pour
sa de l'institut de l'inserm qui
permettent de suivre presque au
quotidien avec tous les moyens
diagnostiques dont nous disposons et
toute la mobilisation de la communauté
scientifique que je remercie pour ça de
suivre l'évolution du variant petit à
petit alors on a plusieurs méthodes vous
avez cité la méthode qui est pilotée par
le professeur bruno lina virologue à
lyon
et qui effectue deux jours par semaine
un séquençage systématique quasiment de
tous les tests pcr positif pourquoi
parce que quand vous faites un test pcr
classique
vous ne pouvez pas identifié s'il s'agit
du coc vide 19 du variant d'origine
anglaise ou du variant d'origine sud
africaine ou d'autres types de variants
et donc ça ça nous permet d'avoir une
vision un jour donné des choses
alors il a fallu quasiment dix jours
pour que l'équipe scientifique puisse
absorber tous les premiers prélèvements
qu'elle avait réalisés nous permettant
de savoir qu'il y avait 3 2% de quatre
variants en circulation en france en
date du 8 janvier mais je suis prêt si
avec vous une étude est reconduite
aujourd'hui et demain les résultats
arriveront au fil de l'eau seront
consolidés dans les prochains jours mais
il faut savoir et c'est là que ça se
complique c'est qu'il y à des tests pcr
développé par une plate forme qu'on
appelle thermo fisher qui permet de
suspecter qu'il s'agisse d'un variant et
dans un certain nombre de cas ces
suspicions sont confirmées en séquençage
génétique et donc sur la base des
milliers de pcr qui sont faites sur
cette plateforme on regarde l'évolution
du nombre de suspicions et là on voit
que ça augmente et vous avez une
troisième méthode telle que nous
déployons depuis ce week-end qui a été
validé très vite en france et en europe
qui sont ces fameuses pcr multiplex qui
sont des pcr classique mais dans les
kits de diagnostics permettent de savoir
s'il s'agit d'un variant ou non et comme
nous confortons l'ensemble de ces
données
nous sommes capables de dire que ce que
j'ai dit tout à l'heure indiquée tout à
l'heure nous étions sans doute à 504
variant par jour en france au début du
mois de janvier ou 8 janvier et nous
sommes désormais à plus de 2000 donc ça
permet de suivre la courbe évolutive des
variantes ce qui permet de savoir à
l'évidence le couvre-feu ne permet pas
d'empêcher le variant en tout cas pas
suffisamment de se développer
et si l'on suit la courbe de
développement de ces variants on peut
rentrer dans un scénario anglaise à la
portugaise ou un espagnol dont vous avez
vu les dégâts que c'était capable de
produire donc c'est pour ça que l'on
fait vraiment du contact et racing très
étroit dès qu'il ya une suspicion de
quatre variants on isole on vérifie tout
celle entourage on dépiste tous les cas
contacts potentiels
on redouble encore de vigilance et
d'efforts et ça c'est une moyen aussi de
freiner la diffusion ces variants
mais ses ministres bonjour cas nicollin
pour tf1 et lci
comment expliquez vous que le couvre-feu
à 18h ne soit pas plus efficace est-ce
que vous avez une idée alors vient
peut-être une étude d'actualité
actualisé je ne sais pas du moment et du
lieu où des lieux auxquels se font les
contaminations depuis le mois de
décembre le mois de janvier
est-ce que c'est toujours
majoritairement en intra familiales est
ce que ça se fait plus ce week end en
semaine parce que vous avez des détails
là dessus il ya des études qui sont
menées
effectivement par les scientifiques je
pense notamment au professeur arnaud
fontanet qui montre les différents
scénarii possibles de contamination il
ya une contamination qui est difficile à
éviter
entre guillemets c'est la contamination
en milieu familial quand vous êtes chez
vous pour partager leurs parents
familles vous ne savez pas vous êtes
porteur du virus et que vous risquer de
contaminer d'autres personnes entre vous
autour de vous il ya des contaminations
qui sont liées à la pratique
professionnelle vous allez par essence
brasser un peu plus de gens c'est pour
ça que le télétravail est extrêmement
utile c'est-à-dire l'une des mesures les
plus utiles pour freiner la diffusion du
virus et des conditions dans lesquelles
on considère et les scientifiques
considèrent qu'on transporte moins on
risque moins de contaminer les personnes
autour de nous c'est quand on peut
porter un masque confère le débat sur
les transports en commun un scientifique
me disais qu'il est proportionnellement
plus de contaminations en covoiturage
quand on porte pas de masque que quand
on est dans transports en commun et
qu'on fait attention et comporte son
masque et qu'on reste à distance et
qu'on a déjà eu droit les coliques donc
c'est pour ça que le comportement de
chacun au quotidien à tous les moments
de la vie
il permet de limiter les risques de
diffusion du virus
quant à vous dire le couvre-feu
clairement il ya eu il a eu un impact
j'en parle au passé et là encore un
impact mais il n'est pas suffisant face
aux variants si je devais résumer si
vous regardez la cour des
hospitalisations dans les quinze
départements dans lesquels nous avons
mis le couvre-feu à 18 heures le 2
janvier donc le plus précoce et bien les
hospitalisations ont été en baisse et
sont en baisse
donc ça veut dire qu'il s'est vraiment
passé quelque chose et je vous le disais
le couvre-feu s'il n'était pas là ma
conviction personnelle profonde c'est
que s'il n'y avait pas de couvre feu
nous n'aurions pas un plateau comme
celui que nous connaissons aujourd'hui
nous aurions une vague épidémique qui
aurait déjà démarré depuis quelques
temps encore une fois donc ça veut dire
que c'est utile n'est pas suffisante
face aux variantes que le variant est
plus contagieux et donc il est capable
de contourner les méthodes dont nous
disposons actuellement
pascal monsieur le ministre je rebondis
justement sur ces questions de
spécialisation que vous évoquez on nous
dit enfin les enquêtes montrent que dans
les structures hospitalières la
situation et dont le fort ambigu il y a
plus d'hospitalisations comme vous le
dites mais que les réanimations
finalement n'augmente pas tant que ça
alors vous avez l'air de dire qu'il y a
quand même des risques de saturation la
question est où et quand à quelle
échéance franchement les hospitaliers
eux-mêmes sont de ce point de vue là pas
toujours aussi inquiet contrairement aux
polémiques qui sont souvent tout à fait
artificielle qui secret sur cette
question là je résume donc des
hospitalisations qui augmente mais des
réanimations pas tant que ça si je
voulais simplifier votre précision vos
précisions
ainsi sous 3000 100 patients atteints de
covin en réanimation 3100 patients
atteints de communes en réanimation
c'est beaucoup c'est beaucoup lorsque
nous avons re confiné au mois d'octobre
je le redis n'y en avait 3300 3400 donc
on est presque au niveau aujourd'hui
d'occupation des animations qui était
celui de la france au mois d'octobre la
grande différence aujourd'hui c'est que
la dynamique n'est pas exponentielle
c'est vrai mais à nouveau le nombre de
réanimation augmente ses actuels je peux
vous citer des exemples d'hôpitaux qui
procède actuellement à des transferts de
patients de réanimation au sein d'une
région c'est le cas notamment de nice
qui est obligé de transférer des malades
parce qu'ils ont trop de malades qui
arrivent en service de réanimation
je vous parlais de la région grand est
de bourgogne franche comté ou des
hôpitaux font face à des fortes tensions
dans les service de réa dans les
services d'accueil des urgences et des
hôpitaux et nous ne sommes pas très loin
d'envisager à nouveau de procéder aux
premiers transferts de patients inter
régionaux pour soulager certaines
régions nous sommes presque à 60 %
d'occupation des lits de réanimation par
des patients atteints de corona des
russes -dont tenant la tension
hospitalière elle est réelle
vingt-sept mille malades d'un hôpital
qui inclut des malades qui sont en
rééducation
c'est ça je pense le sens de votre
question oui nous nous considérons qu'un
patient qui est toujours hospitalisé en
service de rééducation est impatient kif
actuellement est toujours hospitalisé ce
qui n'est pas encore sorti de chez lui
et que les lits de rééducation sont
précieux pour pouvoir soigner des
malades se faire sortir des patients qui
sont dans d'autres types de structures
hospitalières et donc c'est tout le
remplacer l'ensemble de cette pression
hospitalière dont nous tenons compte
nous prenons la dernière question
bonjour frédérique prabonnaud france
télévisions le haut conseil de la santé
publique a rendu public ce matin un avis
où il dit que les soignants positif même
asymptomatiques doivent rester à
l'isolément moins sept jours et qui doit
plus y avoir d'exception
est-ce que vous allez suivre cet avis
d'abord vous dire que la règle c'est
qu'un soignants qui est positif au
coronavirus qu'il soit symptomatique ou
non c'est qu'il reste chez lui en
isolement l'exception c'est que
lorsqu'un hôpital est sous tension on en
parlait à l'instant où lorsqu'un
établissement pour personnes âgées est
sous tension et qu'il faut du personnel
soignant pour pouvoir soigner les
malades
si le soignant est asymptomatique ou si
les cas contacts dans ces situations là
eh bien il peut être ils peuvent
proposer d'aller travailler en unité
qu'ovide en portant un masque et en
faisant attention en 8es copine parce
que les gens ont déjà le co vite dans
l'unité le haut conseil de santé
publique nous dit limiter au plus
possible ces situations là nous
l'entendons encore une fois oui même
plus loin il dit évitez tout court ces
situations là c'est une évidence
je pourrais écrire exactement la même
chose que le haut conseil de santé
publique
néanmoins nous devons compte tenir
compte des réalités locales lire
situation propre à chaque service
hospitalier donc nous travaillons avec
le hcsp nous travaillons avec l'ensemble
des sociétés françaises dans le domaine
de la santé pour trouver le moyen
d'aller encore plus loin dans l'éviction
des soignants lorsqu'ils sont positifs
ou cas contacts de manière à leur
permettre de garantir toujours le
respect d'isolement s'il y avait des
situations entre guillemets extrême ou
si un médecin asymptomatiques s'il ne
vient pas ne permet pas d'assurer des
soins des malades forcément nous
travaillons aussi à ce type de scénario
mais je rappelle que la règle avant la
recommandations du hcsp
elle est que quelqu'un qu'ils soient
positifs qu'ils soient soignés ou non
quand il est positif aucun contact
respectez les allemands je vous remercie